lorsque le chef de l'état prend la
parole pour le centenaire de la
naissance de françois mitterrand toute
la gauche gouvernementale est présente
paris si je doit siffler la récréation
où le début du match c'est le
rassemblement
leurs ascendants parce qu'il n'y aura
qu'à ce candidat les anciens ministre
les actuelles
les représentants de la majorité mais il
ya un grand absent
quand on est dans la vie politique
depuis longtemps de ne pas supporter
d'avoir à l'épiderme fragile un
président de l'assemblée ne va pas faire
ça claude bartolone ici au perchoir plus
tôt dans la journée s'est bien rendu aux
commémorations
avant de quitter la salle quand françois
hollande a pris la parole parce que je
reproche à ceux qui aujourd'hui à partir
d'un livre fait nerv fait dommage qu'il
soit pas énervé au moment de la loi
travail
interrogé sur une possible nomination de
claude bartolone à matignon le chef de
l'état a exclu catégoriquement
il n'a pas l'envergure il n'est pas très
connu le jour où il le deviendrait il
n'a pas un charisme considérable on a vu
qu'à une petite enquête qui vient de
sortir très particulière 4% s'est encore
pas mal mais lui voulait rassembler au
débat bah oui il a rassemblé
l'opposition et l'opposition contre lui
on m'appelle le maquereau du petit
journal jeunes look est faible ambitieux
écoutez je prends ça comme un hommage et
si ça peut vous porter chance eux ravis
car ils sont amusés à regarder quelle
était la cote de popularité du président
de la république six mois avant
l'élection suivante alors que vous avez
quelques conseils à mener pour françois
hollande évidemment c'est une sorte
d'ascensions de l'everest vous voyez il
est tout en bas de la côte à gauche en
compagnie de nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs
vouloir persister à être président de la
république alors qu'ils sont rejetés
l'un comme l'autre
effectivement il ya une part de
masochisme ou alors de déconnexion avec
la réalité
alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy se sont
donné rendez vous à marseille pour un
duel à distance n'est pas coupable
d'avoir voulu faire partager sa culture
aux peuples d'afrique d'asie et
d'amérique du nord
c'est ce que vous voteriez françois
hollande contre le front national
si la situation se présente et passée
pro pour la rentrer dans une longue
tradition de propos racistes que
tiennent les dirigeants pour les flics
français à l'égard de l'afrique et de
nouveau chez n'ai jamais voté pour son
nationale je suis pas l'intention de le
faire dont voiturier pour françois
hollande
pas de gaieté de coeur c'est la grande
île et moi je me suis dit est-ce qu'il
est sincère ce monsieur bourdin ou par
quand il veut et puis tous les matins
que vous voyez je me dis pas tous les
matins s'il vous plaît il faut que je
récompense tant d'insistance pour
m'avoir si j'ai pensé figurez vous je
vous manqué on s'attarde ça tombe bien
on m'a demandé d'intervenir
et quand 50 monsieur fillon il parle
plus que moi je reviens